here we are architecture between meaning
emotion and function so first of all I
am glad that you endured the whole day
and that you will you stayed with us
because there was a crescendo during the
whole afternoon
um and we started I actually we we kind
of created this kind of circular path
and we've been talking about systems and
prototypes and experiments throughout
different scales and throughout
different kinds of design for the whole
afternoon and I'm so glad to get to this
one grand finale that's composed of two
segments and I'm going to introduce the
first segment the first segment is a
dear friend that is also an honorary
Singaporean I think you should give him
the the keys of the city at this point
he really strives to infuse his
buildings and his works with originality
inventiveness of course but also
humanity and actually recently he
started talking very openly about the
inhumanity of so much of the
architecture that we already see so I
think it's quite it makes a lot of sense
that he found in Singapore another home
away from home like many others and that
is Thomas heatherwick of course and he's
going to be interviewed by the
outstanding Irwin Beret that I just met
he's the head of Chief sustainability
officer of the Singapore University of
Technology and design sutd which is also
a partner for the organization of that
this afternoon Symposium but you know I
had heard about him before and I had
heard how wise and Suave and Humane and
spiritual he is but not until I met him
in person did I realize that that was
all true so I think that the dialogue
between the two between Thomas and Irwin
will be quite unique I would like to
First Call On Stage Thomas who's going
to give a presentation on his own and
then Irwin is going to join him on stage
so Thomas please come
[Applause]
the pressure is massive after the
amazing speakers and I don't know if you
all saw the the torch That Gets Zapped
by Paula she's changed that after after
dinner to an electrocution thing in the
back so if you see me starting twitching
you'll know power's on to me
um I I wanted to
talk to us all together about
streets with new buildings on
and the problem that we all know exists
in our towns and cities around the world
that we're increasingly surrounded by
characterless buildings
I believe we're living through an
epidemic of boringness
everywhere's the same
dull flat shiny straight inhuman
these buildings are what my daughter
calls meh buildings
and I'm a designer of buildings and I've
been told so many times that forms
should follow function meaning that if I
work out with my team how mechanically a
building should go together that somehow
the outcome will be great
this Mantra form follows function is a
century old and it sounds good doesn't
it who can argue with that surely any
extra detail is just silly unnecessary
decoration
but I want to talk about
the function that I believe is missing
the function of emotion
and when I say motion I mean the ability
of buildings to lift our spirits to
connect us together
we walk Round buildings we look up at
them and most of the time they just
leave us feeling indifferent
so if I was to take everyone
to a city
and say where would you like to go to
would you like to go to the old bit
or the new bit
I'm pretty sure that most people in this
room will pick the old bit
why because we all know that the new bit
will be monotonous and boring
and
so what's happened to all the lumps and
bumps on buildings the Shadows the
textures the high points of light how
did it all become so monolithic and
devoid of character
but it seems that I'm not the only one
alarmed at what's happening in our towns
and cities there's research showing that
these buildings
aren't just
monolithic and inhuman
they're also giving stress in our brains
as we walk around them
that they're so they're bad for us
individually
they're bad for our health making us
take longer to heal inside those
buildings and they're bad for society
increasing the chances of crime and
anti-social behavior in and around them
but this gets most alarming
when we step back and think about the
climate crisis unfolding around us
huge emphasis has been put on the impact
of Aviation for example and Aviation is
responsible for 2.1 percent in 2019 of
greenhouse gas emissions
but the crazy elephant in the room
is that the building industry as a whole
is responsible for 38 of greenhouse gas
emissions that's 15 times
the impact of Aviation
and in America
a billion square foot are built at the
building are destroyed
every year and rebuilt that's the size
of half of Washington
and in the UK we just demolish 50 000
buildings every year
and the average age of a commercial
building is 40 years
so if I had been born as a commercial
building I'd have been killed 12 years
ago
so it's it the evidence evidence is
clear
that when people don't love buildings
they're more likely to demolish them
so there are there are a small handful
of people who do understand this and are
trying to make a difference uh and I
just thought I'd show four of the ways
that my studio has been trying to think
about this
and so when thinking about healing
in the UK we had the chance to think
about a non-clinical building at the
UK's largest Cancer Care Center the
Cancer Care Hospital
and when you think about the worst
environments maybe not here in Singapore
but in the UK and most other places I've
been to the worst places you can
possibly imagine
they tend to be Health environments
and so we were given this site
which was in the last green site on the
hospital did you catch that you see that
last bit of green sight
and actually it wasn't really a green
site because that was just the
construction waste left over from the
car park next door with a bit of turf
bung on top of it
and so we didn't want to be the ones to
wipe out the last bit of greenery
when we knew that there's a power to
that Greenery that can contribute to
Healing
and so we got we decided to use natural
materials and you know those dinosaur
models that you can get in like science
museum shops that are made from plywood
we use gigantic version of this plywood
where the wood itself is
is has embodied carbon trapped within it
and we made a building that is three
Gardens
and it has
eighteen thousand plants and 23 000
bulbs and a net biodiversity increase of
436 percent
and it's all breathable materials
and a key part of our brief was
designing spaces that you could cry in
and be together with your thoughts but
also come together as a group
I had to to deal with this thing that
doesn't have to be a death sentence
automatically
but a key to our Focus was things the
details and aspects that could humanize
and make something feel that there was
care and attention which typically the
hospital environment is something that
tells you that there isn't really
empathy and care
when thinking about spaces you can live
in
I felt I had to show the experiment that
we had a chance to do here in Singapore
to build a housing Tower
and when we think of amazing projects in
the worlds of housing Singapore really
has so many incredible projects and we
were seeing some of those earlier and
when we were thinking about building
apartments in a in a country that is a
city I was brought up in London in a in
a terraced house
and you if you left your socks on the
top floor you're going up and down
trying to carry your socks and the drink
and try not to spill them when you go
downstairs all those funny things about
living in a Terrace which on multiple
floors and then the handiness of living
in an apartment horizontally is
fantastic
but
the thing that I didn't want to leave
behind when I think of living is the
smell of the earth and that being
connected to the ground and I know here
in Singapore these black and white
houses are so cherished because of that
relationship in this tropical context of
nature but so how do you change the
dynamic of being in a weird helicopter
flying above the landscape
to really connecting closer with nature
so we wondered could we make every
apartment have its own garden
and Monsoon was speaking earlier about
cross-ventilation we've visited all the
different department buildings we
possibly could and they all felt like a
prison of glass with maybe a dry balcony
that you'd look out at never go out
because it was too hot and we just
visited one where suddenly there was
this cross ventilation and we just
realized that must we must have air
moving across
so we made a project where there is a
garden
on every floor where on three different
sides you can open it up and let the for
a few hours of the day potentially not
use that heavy duty air conditioning
that everyone relies on so much here
and make a project
which
is based on embedding Garden
365 degrees around you
um
360. and just testing where they're all
awake there but where you don't have a
lobby with a kind of artwork and a
Cheesy piano or something but you just
walk into a garden and in that Garden
there are some elevators that can take
you to your apartment
and where that nature is embedded into
this the space rather than stuck on as
an addition later
and it was sort of interesting having
the chance to finish this project two
three years ago but uh now with the
covet experience we shared where so many
people were locked in that importance of
something that I think is deep in US of
connecting to Nature is is I think quite
fundamental
and
I also thought I'd talk about learning
and our amazing client is here tonight
who commissioned us to think at nanyang
Technical University about how we could
make a learning space for flipped
learning so learning where
acknowledging that why you used to go to
university because that's where all the
books were and you used to go to
university because that's where the
computers were to write the essays with
the books and maybe meet some professors
but now that you can line bed and get a
PhD
why do you go there
and so the first conversations together
were so exciting just thinking what's
because that's where you want to meet
people so when you say a university
building should be for meeting people
the existing environment
with miles of these dead corridors with
no daylight polystyrene ceiling tiles
and hard buildings going to be a 24-hour
building so when you imagine sending
your daughter at two o'clock in the
morning down mile two just thought right
we must make a corridor less University
Building
but also there was a real hunger to move
away from the guru and slave model to
learning in the realm together and the
university said to us no corners in the
tutorial rooms so we obeyed
and so we made a building made from 12
of these and the focus really was just
knowing that we we tend to learn where
you're not supposed to learn so how
could we make as many nooks and crannies
spaces
for the bit before or the bit after
where you think I don't disagree with
what they said or that I'm not sure
about and so it's got lots of
conspiratorial huddle spaces but
everyone can see each other so the
finished building isn't one building
it's 12 buildings that collaborate
and our passion was to try to work
towards finding what a tropical
sustainable architecture might be
evolving towards
and to embed craftsmanship and to make a
space that so there's no air
conditioning it uses cross ventilation
here to try and make a heart to a
building where everyone can see each
other
where that's that Spirit of the teachers
are there to learn with you not dictate
to you and spaces where you can be in
multiple levels of uh
um formality and collaborating qualities
and I remember going along there one
time when I was here with jet lag at two
in the morning and and its building
doesn't need any doors because it's open
24 hours and there there were people uh
learning
so um
um I'm I finally
uh in New York that we were commissioned
to make a piece a public Space Project
and here was the old Pier 55
I pay 54 sorry and we were asked to make
a new pair this had got damaged as a
public space and they ex we were being
asked to enlarge the edge of Manhattan
here and what seemed most exciting to us
was not being on a bigger bit of
Manhattan but enjoying the
infrastructure and and of how you make
peers and watering us not bigger
Manhattan with the nine Lanes of highway
there
and so it seemed making a part putting a
few trees on that Windswept
horizontality seemed a shame so he's
with thinking about the emotion of being
in space and being in nature and it
seemed a few plants on that
windsweptness wouldn't do anything so
could we let
the piles be the hero and
three-dimensionalize and really lift up
a space
so a year and a half ago we finished
this new park which is pushed out off
from the city and is a space with
gangplanks across so that you have the
emotion of leaving something behind and
arriving at something new
and it's a space for the city it's free
and almost every production in the
outdoor theater is subsidized and it's
really about spaces that are a platform
for the city
so
in conclusion I I'm not saying there's
any one solution
for this epidemic of boring
just like in nature we've learned the
immense importance of biodiversity
I believe we now desperately need more
architectural diversity
my My Hope Is that we could together
trigger a new humanizing movement that
no longer tolerates soulless in human
spaces
and we can't keep knocking down all the
old buildings all the time
wouldn't it be better if those buildings
inspired us to want to adapt and adjust
and repair them
so my hope is that we stop building
40-year buildings and we start building
a Thousand-Year buildings
thank you
and perfect timing I read the perfect
timing tonight perfect timing like five
to ten seconds over like perfect
yeah I totally am and this is for you
Erwin beret
foreign
[Applause]
thank you good evening everyone thank
you so much for the uh wonderful sharing
on the possibility of a diversity in
architecture and a very human
architecture I hope you're comfortable
in the chair you're sitting up the
boring chair yes and then I will be
sitting in this sexy chair which I think
I should be careful with because
it's actually quite comfortable
um palum am I allowed to pour him some
water
yeah okay look away Oh I thought I was
supposed to be the one boring you
somewhat yeah okay thank you very much
everyone thank you
okay
yeah I should have bought you the water
shall we give a toast
thank you cheers he's very Suave isn't
he
thank you
now let's go to the hard part
um
I I started with a chair because I was
recalling one scene whereby uh Baron
Jacob Rochelle in his Flint house in in
buckinghamshire
had this spawn chair
designed by you and so
uh Baron Rose child is about almost 90
years old and so I said oh you have this
chair so do you sit on the chair and so
he said oh would you want me to show you
that I could sit on the chair
and that's how he started sitting on the
chairs finding himself on the chair
and then it made me see him as a
nine-year-old
and and so I think that when we do our
design when we look at the world and
create things I think there are certain
moments in our lives that actually
affect us and then guide us in the
things that we do and then in one
interview that you gave there was one
scene whereby you actually shared the
has a weak studio is your room as a
nine-year-old maybe you can Enlighten us
on this what is this room as a
nine-year-old
um okay uh well I was brought up in a
suburb of London and
in uh
a house that was a kind of big rambling
house and
back in those days parents didn't have
to spend much time with their children
and so I was sort of left alone with a
kind of
uh slightly ruined house and there were
jumble sales back then and so
uh because I had quite a big room you
could sort of collect stuff
and so it's just a cliche I was taking
things apart doing things like that
people say people like me always say
that don't they yes
um and so uh but I
all my friends had fitted carpet whereas
I had some old rolled up bit of one that
my mum had got thrown away and
um so it felt like a a room with
different experiments and things going
on and you sort of as you were learning
about like
camera that you could take apart the
mechanism of the iris or and there was
the smell of electronic things because
very cheaply at a jumble sale you could
get calculating machines you know the
leftovers from before the digital
Revolution that was kind of coming and
so there's a particular smell of those
kinds of things and I had tools and I
just got left to it no one asked me what
I wanted to be when I grew up they just
sort of
left you to it it was let you be bored
which then you fill that Gap somehow
that's uh very good to hear I think it's
impressive that when you're describing
it you're actually evoking the senses in
the sand the smell and the ductility of
things and I think that maybe sometimes
in the abstract reasoning and thinking
that we do we forget about these things
uh and then we always maybe forget that
creation is the emergent of things it's
actually in how you do things when you
break a break apart things and then put
them together that you actually discover
things and then it actually shows that
emergence itself is actually
self-organized and also organized by the
others and you also mentioned that oh
you cannot just work by yourself you
actually like to work with other people
and so collaboration becomes very
important and so it means that maybe
creating this Grand Design is not just
by this lone genius but actually it's
because of the interaction with people
and that makes it very human and and
then with this interaction I think that
it evokes memories you create memories
together and then I think that these
memories are actually quite important
and in the projects that you have shared
about Singapore you seem to be reading
spaces and memories associated with it
and and so like when you read through
the black and white Bungalows and then
you read through uh this being
translated into the Eden itself the
cross ventilation the Garden on every
floor in my own memory I'm transported
also to my childhood when I was nine
years old to the Shangri-La Hotel of
that time that it's actually like Eden
also it's Shangri-La where you have this
the inside outside natural ventilation
and then the green everywhere and so I
think that you are evoking maybe it's my
impression a lot of
memories and which is a very important
part in creating things and I think I
was speaking to you the other day about
this Christian Madeleine moment that
it's about Marcel Bruce in his novel
other relationship the terms
uh remembrance of things past whereby he
was coming from the freezing cold and
then he comes in and then his aunt
actually gave him a warm cup of tea and
then the Madeleine the cell shape
cook cakes and then so he dips this into
the
warm tea and then takes it in and then
as soon as this warm tea and then the
motherland touches his palate he's
transported to kombre and his childhood
memories and so I feel that maybe it's
also the same when you were describing
these projects that you have shown like
even the the dinosaurs for the Maggie
Center and and it's bringing you to
Childhood itself so
um I think that it would be nice for you
to maybe hear you speak about these
memories and then how it could help you
maybe uh in creating that future design
for Singapore and then maybe what
Memories you have so far of Singapore
that could help you uh create the
prototype for the future of architecture
a diverse human architecture in
Singapore
so you heard that Irwin was referencing
proust there
in our conversation before he was also
talking about the
um cartoon Ratatouille as well I don't
know if any of you have seen that for
some similar things
um but I think my my feeling is that the
years ago
um
I got interested in dots very British
and when darts you're trying to
obviously hit the bullseye or witch bit
and you when you throw your first Dart
you you're likely to sort of throw to
the left or to the right and then the
next start you're likely to
overcompensate and go to the other thing
and then you're trying with your third
Dart to get the middle between those two
things
and it feels like we had a form of
architecture
that was human
without having to have a big
intellectual conversation about why it
was human
then we threw it all away
because it didn't seem relevant to our
time and then we threw away the craft
and then we got very excited about
system thinking
and there was a war and the the this
seemed a perfect place for systems
strategic thinking to go in
and there was an academicization
of that profession
and the the head lead it
without the balancing empathy and the
heart and we the it's proudly spoken of
as science you know architectures like
science with some art in it
and the and it really I think I
intuitively felt there was a a gap yeah
as a child and so I'm interested in gaps
that's what inspires me it's not
expressing myself we can see it in the
NTU Learning Center so we're driven by a
problem yes and that's drive so I can
logically explain everything even some
of you may have seen are UK Pavilion in
Shanghai which was the world's biggest
ever hairy building sounds irrational
my argument is this is like a new
rationalism
but where emotion is sitting alongside
the functions that you have to think
about and I think the artificial
intelligence that's coming up the
analytical tools we now have are going
to be able are going to make the
argument in the past that was well it's
very subjective Beauty that's subjective
are we going to start having objective
things which are not I don't really use
the word beauty but there are things to
do with repetition and complexity and
the environments I was showing that
leave you cold what they have in common
is an absence of complexity and you get
that complexity when you look at nature
and you look into this immense
complexity
and buildings from the past often had a
lot of complexity
and we have to find our ways to build
that human complexity back in and so I
suppose
that the profession has also got very
humorless
and the places we love and the people we
love they're often silly I've never
heard and it was like you can't say
silly you're spending a hundred million
dollars to do something
very serious yes and I just think we've
gotten into some funny cul-de-sac
where it's binary it's like the only way
to connect with that is to somehow copy
the past and I don't think you need to
copy the past to be human
and so that's a sort of research line
that me and my team are on but in a
sense I think that means you have to
keep tuning back into feelings and
thinking and I remember hearing someone
saying use yourself as data you know
often people hide with every everyone
else's data but I think feeling is a
strong thing and so I My Hope
for architectural education
and Builder and Builders education and
property developer education is that we
get more used to talking about emotion
again I think in the social World
between us we are now we know that a
relationship won't last if in the old
kind of cliche of husband and wife and
that real relationships you you need to
find ways to connect with your emotion
and be vulnerable and all of those kind
of things that now feel boring to say
but that world of the building hasn't
had that and has got stuck and it's it
worships the same Masters who keep
perpetuating something that isn't human
so yes
it seems like we're so obsessed with
measuring things I guess and so how do
you measure emotions
so I think that it's maybe a some big
question that how do I know that my
emotion is correct or wrong how do I
know if it is appropriate or not
appropriate would you be asking this
when when you do things and and look at
things
I think that there's a sort of
retraining of public confidence because
building people feel so powerless about
buildings happening and the planning
system kind of plays on that and if you
so
you know if there's a planning
application in the UK
well if you think about how Nike wants
if they want to
um promote a new shoe
how well they're going to do that just
and then you think about if you're going
to promote a planning application you
might want people's thoughts on you know
there's a piece of A4 paper in a plastic
sleeve which has been cable tied onto a
lamp column in London getting wet and
you have to peer at it and it's just
jargon and there's nothing inviting your
thoughts it's actually a a miserable uh
statement of not wanting people involved
and engaged and I'm not sure I'm
answering your question but I'm what's
your question again
what did I ask you
back to Power okay okay yeah I thought
that it was about measure but how do you
measure it how do you measure well I
think that measuring is coming yes
because we are now getting the if we go
back to the um
a metaverse some of the headsets that
are coming and I was speaking to the
person developing with apple their
headsets
the intelligence we we've thought
emotion is just subjectively but there's
Now tracking software that can tell the
emotion in your eye movements that
that's the Zone which gives away and
it's not just where your retina is
pointing
so we're going to start because as it is
we can do eye tracking to see where
people's eyes are and when you start
looking at the way they track buildings
with necessary visual complexity and
buildings with absence of any of that
you see how their eyes move so that that
the neuroscience and the neuroscientists
working on this it's it's really growing
and I think that that's going to start
becoming interestingly unarguable data
where you'll be able to objectively say
whether something connects or doesn't
and whether and we've already got data
on buildings that cause stress because
with electrodes connected you can really
see how people's brains are responding
and I just love that because I think
we're gonna find that that's coming back
with a kind of Vengeance yes that if we
don't want to be 15 times worse than the
aviation industry and really be doing
buildings that are going to
stay in the long term that's going to be
fascinating data and instead of
building designers making buildings for
the appreciation of other building
designers and winning awards from other
building designers and the disconnection
of what building designers think is
great and what the public think is great
I think we're going to have a correction
time
that's going to be fascinating over the
next few decades yeah it's fascinating
to imagine what what you are sharing
from us that
yeah the possibilities that we can do is
understanding ourselves understanding
our body how we react to things and then
how things our environment could
actually affect how we feel and then how
would we would uh
do things like in this space like can
you turn around in your chair I don't
have the features yourself
you see that yeah maybe just to show
that okay the the increments given to us
allow us to do certain things and so
status You're just showing off yeah I'm
showing off sorry
I'm sorry
Paula sorry about this
yeah but anyway yeah so when because you
mentioned the aviation industry and then
somehow when we think of these the eye
movement we think of a certain intimacy
and a certain scale when we measure
things but what happens when you come to
bigger things uh huge spaces and and and
so how do you make that
uh a space that could be a comfortable
space and then how would you
uh create a certain emotion in spaces
like that what emotions would that be so
like maybe you have not shown it today
and and one um project that I have in
mind is the Google headquarters also
because that's a huge scale of
the environment itself
like magic
[Music]
um yes uh okay that was a clever lead
yes
um thank you so
um the we've just finished this four
months ago we finished the first phase
of the Google build
ings
um in Mountain View in California
and the existing buildings were
that they were using I mean they all had
a Tarmac tutu of cars around the outside
of them and the it was very
disappointing going to California there
when I was there arriving thinking this
place has changed the world and how the
built environment and some of the most
intelligent people in the world are
there and the built-in environment
wasn't expressing that at all and
I also find it fascinating that we are
the magnitude of what some of these
companies have done and facilitated us
to do
and but then actually the little people
that we need to make workspace for
are the same size roughly we were about
400 000 years ago
and our needs and probably in another
few thousand years would probably be
maybe a little bit taller a little
smaller if we exist at all
um and so it was interesting thinking
how do you make spaces that can take
future change
but also
can have so the flexibility is there but
also
when we make sustainable buildings
so typically someone designs their
building and then like Post-it notes
they think oh I've got to be sustainable
and stick a few uh solar panels on and
so instead these buildings are giant
sheet of like dragon scale solar panels
draped across
so that you the entire building is one
semi-rigid solar panel and so generating
40 percent of the building's power and
then the another 40 is taken from the
ground from the uh from the biggest use
of geothermal
cooling pipes into the piles that make
it and the space is making something so
that inside you can treat it as a space
within which you could make balloons or
you could make driverless cars or
whatever the future holds
um and this is by the way in
collaboration with big who were
mentioned earlier who recommended
Singapore for Westworld
um but the the key thing is again about
emotion and we didn't know covid was
coming but how could you make spaces
that are as different from home as
possible and most work environments are
so uh we're working on the basis that
you're a prisoner of your boss and your
boss is kind of like Stockholm Syndrome
has you in a headlock five days a week
and two days a week they let you out and
they get you back on Monday and and that
that Dynamic really is busted when
someone's only going in two days a week
because we all like to tell a story to
ourselves that our decisions are valid I
love my boss he's great you know and so
and when you're five days you could have
a fourth day it was a bit rubbish on
Thursday and be a bit annoyed and then
coming on Friday and it'd be okay and
everyone goes for drinks but now that
people are maybe only going in three
days or two days and if they have a bad
day on that third day then they go home
in fester for four days that you're
going to get more professionally
promiscuous
Workforce and so the work the space has
to be a temple of the values of your
organization whatever whether you're
Google whoever the smallest organization
so that when you do go and you get a
kind of shot of that importance so for
me
amidst the tragedy of covid has been the
revolution in actually having to listen
to our intuitions and urges because you
you don't imprison each other anymore
you have to think of people's
motivations and motivations are
primitive and sort of simple in many
ways but it's about we all have the
delusion we're special eight billion of
us do and so you have to make places
that support someone feeling that they
are special because we are special at
the same time as being mundane and Tiny
and ordinary and so I'm I think that
we've been we've treated people as if
they are a number when in transportation
in workspace and I'm re personally my
passion is the public space that we
share together and how public space
needs to be our people's palaces and
that we have had some weird stupid
notion I think Paula what did you call
it earlier I'm sorry I took a note of
what Paula said you no longer need to
abdicate Beauty in order to show piety
we've had this weird kind of national
beat ourselves up and make a kind of
basic don't overspend money on public
stuff and instead we after cliche we
always spend like art gallery Art
Gallery let's make it artistic oh
it's like oh every city does the same
formulas it's like why not make the
hospital the most culturally artistic
interesting place and the Art Gallery
can just be a big Ikea shed
and it's just and that would actually
feel fresh for just a little bit more
you can make the best hospital on the
planet
and so I just think I'm more interested
in the Strategic decisions than me
designing deciding is it going to be
hairy or ripply or what where do you do
we put the love in society which sounds
sentimental again the architectural
world
except Mark we yes who's done his
lovability index which I'm sure you must
talk about which was I loved hearing
about Singapore's lovability index I
thought that was really interesting
that's very good uh Thomas because
you're answering the question that you
asked me before we started and then I
looked at you you asked what has changed
after the pandemic with you what what
and then so I looked at you and I said
what has changed but I think that you
have actually shared it in a certain way
and there is a question here I think
that could be related to what you were
sharing tell us about Changi Terminal 5
please oh but before you say that I
would have to tell you the importance of
Changi Airport terminal 5. I think many
people are curious about it
not Magic
and
in the National Day rally speech of
prime minister lisian long he has
emphasized the important role of the
Changi Airport especially Terminal 5 as
one of the pillars of the infrastructure
to bring Singapore to the Future and
then so Changi Airport is a special
place for singaporeans and for Singapore
it is a place where people leave work
and play and also symbolize the
aspirations of Singapore itself it's
openness to the world to receive people
to send people and it is a beloved place
Singapore and so the Singapore
has given a lot of trust to you it has
given you its love
and so maybe can you see the body
language
you could share a bit about Terminal 5
and maybe the ideas of well that love
for Terminal 5 and the area around
Changi Airport
so we are collaborating with Cohn
Peterson Fox on this project
and I think we're I'm we actually have
the leaders of Changi
yam and xiaohang Li are here who've
commissioned this and it's
I mean I shall said people's palaces
didn't I earlier and actually
if you this whole day has been based
around this agency of the future and I
really you can see in the work I've
shown that I've I've had a chance I hope
to think about that to me Singapore
really is this agency of the future I'm
I'm embarrassed that 15 years ago
there was I had a mentor called Terence
conran who started habitat which was the
inspiration for Ikea and I met him when
I was a student and he was incredible
just a random student person he let me
live at his house
and helped me do something when I just
tapped him on the shoulder in a corridor
and the he had a dinner a lunch for a
group of delegates from Singapore 15
years ago to talk about what design
could be and getting inspiration from
the UK and I remember thinking I hadn't
traveled much so our International
delegation on a kind of Jolly from
somewhere they've all had their flights
paid and they were having a nice lunch
at terence's restaurant because he has
amazing restaurants and so I remember
thinking ah blah blah everyone has a
nice chat and goes back and Carries on
doing the same things they're doing
before
but no
as Paula was talking about
the super hero civil servants here were
not just on that and I just watched as
came back
made Gardens by the bay happen Marina
Bay Sands happened all these things like
design you know the design Council here
that's frankly I think better than the
British design Council
um
[Applause]
okay
I don't think this isn't going to go
live is it this is not going to be on
the inside of it okay
um but so I so for me the gravity of a
country which has
it is this is one communal city state
the airport is isn't the thing over
there to go it's sort of a heart of a
community
and so the first conversations
with the airport team was thrilling and
it was
the most could you close your ears
please client group the most intelligent
is the most intelligent client group
we've ever had really yeah
and um and so the level of conversation
and willingness to engage in
conversations about emotion
so uh obviously I'm not allowed to say
anything much at the moment about two
things but I hope what you see in this
Sim
you haven't got big hair getting in the
way or anything like that so it's okay
my my head is shining it might overpower
this
so um what this what you see here really
will be the biggest use of photovoltaics
in the world of Aviation
but that's what the real goal is to not
see we talk about Cathedral size spaces
and actually
many spaces called cathedral-sized
spaces are way smaller than Cathedrals
and this is so much bigger than any
Cathedral I mean this is from the Marina
Bay all the way to the Singapore River I
mean this is and this will be one of the
biggest terminals ever made in history
as big as terminal one two three and
four combined
and so it's not about making one place
it's about making many places
and the relationships and it's a sort of
I'm not quite Community Center Social
Hub
for a nation and a city and so it's so
it's really interesting
thinking about that job and that's so
social social job
commitment that we all have to something
that is giving and it's not it's not for
the airlines this is this is for people
and uh well I mean you all know that
Changi has won for the last like 20
years the best airport of the Year
business one and for the last eight
years something
um best from passengers but because
because the team have thought from the
passenger rather than from the airline
making Airlines happy instead of that
focusing on the passengers but this is
more than passengers this is a Social
Hub
and so I'm I feel very honored and
responsible and
scared but
um and uh by the way I only think I
think we won the competition because I
think we were the only team where like I
might still be alive when it's finished
so I think it was the kind of default
thing
there were some really good people in
the competition but
um yes Thomas I think that you have
shared it and we could feel the love
that you have for the Changi Airport
terminal 5. and and I think that it's
something that we will look forward to
that when that I I will just share that
again in terms of memories uh Changi
Airport has many memories
maybe I speak for myself but for
everyone there are many of these and so
I think that you will be with us in
these memories and thank you very much
thank you thank you
thank you very much Irwin and Thomas